bonjour claude bonjour heureuse de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale d'arreter
france anthony blinken qui est donc en
malaisie pourquoi cette opération de
séduction dans une période de tension de
fortes tensions même avec la chine en
effet il arrive aujourd'hui en malaisie
et c'est particulièrement important
parce que la malaisie est l'un des trois
pays d'asie du sud est qui avait été
invité à la fin de la semaine dernière à
participer par joe biden au sommet
virtuel sur les sur sur la sur la
démocratie et il se trouve que la
malaisie a fait la mauvaise tête et a
décliné l'invitation n'a pas participé
en disant que cette réunion était mal
préparé que c'étaient les états unis qui
les liait les pays démocratiques et que
par ailleurs ça paraissait trop agressif
vis-à-vis d'achille en effet la chine a
dénoncé cette initiative comme l'appelle
à une étape coalition une croisade anti
anti chinoises en revanche l'indonésie
qui était l'étape d'hier a participé le
1er août jour où coco a participé à cet
assaut à ce sommet en disant qu'
évidemment l'indonésie était favorable
au développement de la démocratie
partout dans le monde
le troisième pays c'était les
philippines qui sont pas tout à fait un
modèle de démocratie alors c'est
important parce que comme vous l'avez
dit
pour les états unis l'ensemble des pays
d'asie du sud-est sont une pièce
essentielle de leur stratégie indo
pacifique
les etats unis ont déjà une alliance
militaire avec le japon avec la corée du
sud maintenant avec l'australie une base
à guam sont très implantés par
conséquent souhaite compléter cette
ceinture de containment de l'expansion
chinoise notamment en mer de chine du
sud et pour assurer souhaite assurer la
liberté de circulation dans les détroits
notamment le détroit de malacca par où
passe une part très importante du
commerce international c'est aussi la
région se trouve taiwan et les états
unis en profite pour rappeler leur
attachement à la liberté de circulation
dans le détroit de taiwan
il n'y en qu'un jour ou l'autre les
chinois ils mettent des entraves alors
claude nicolaï pas trop de chefs le
secrétaire du conseil de sécurité de la
fédération de russie a déclaré vouloir
conserver je cite larchitecture de
sécurité dans la région pacifique que
faut-il comprendre
sur votre chef est un personnage très
important dans le système russe et sa
déclaration est importante elle est un
peu un peu surprenante parce que en
réalité actuellement
lille architecture de sécurité s'il y en
a une en asie c'est grosso modo celle
qui tourne autour de l'asian c'est à
dire des dix pays de l'asie du sud-est
dont je viens de parler qui en effet on
élaborait une structure qui fait que
chaque année ils ont un dialogue
collectif avec successivement les
etats-unis la russie la chine et l'union
européenne mais ce sont des réunions
relativement informel ou dans le fond il
se passe pas grand chose
et puis par ailleurs il ya comme je les
dis aussi tout à l'heure la présence de
la 7e flotte qui joue un rôle important
dans la liberté de circulation dans les
détroits et sur les mers alors je pense
que me ce que monsieur pas trop de chefs
veut dire c'est que il ne souhaite pas
que les américains qui sont déjà très
présents dans la zone high plus loin et
que peut-être à tout prendre il préfère
la situation actuelle c'est à dire le
conservatisme plutôt qu'une haute en
puissance de la chine dans toutes ces
mères de mer de chine du sud et de
l'océan pacifique alors l'europe et la
france en particulier que vont-elles
perdu tout appui dans la région et si
vous non pourquoi égouttez non l'europe
a conclu un certain nombre d'accords de
coopération nouvelle génération les plus
connus sont ceux avec singapour et et
avec le vietnam vietnam qui d'ailleurs
eu quelques difficultés dans le projet
la procédure de ratification à cause de
la situation politique et les droits de
l'homme au vietnam et finalement le
vietnam a convaincu y compris au
parlement européen que cet accord était
un bon moyen de l'aider à aller dans le
bon sens l'aider à se développer
progressivement à se libéraliser et puis
un autre qui également sont en
négociation avec la malaisie et avec
d'autres pays d'asie du sud est
l'union européenne a aussi un accord de
libre échange avec la corée du sud à un
accord du même type avec le japon donc
l'union européenne et est très présente
avec des cotations très active avec tous
ces pays la france pour sa part est
aussi un acteur dans les domaines de sa
compétence le cadre commercial c'est
évidemment l'union européenne mais pour
le reste la france à des dialogues
stratégiques avec la plupart de ces pays
qu'il s'agisse du vietnam du japon de la
corée du sud
de la zone en tant que tel et des
différents pays de la diane bien sûr
l'offre sauf lorsqu'il s'agit de
dictature militaire ce qui est le cas
actuellement de la birmanie et ceux qui
aussi le cas du pays que visitera
monsieur blinken demain c'est à dire la
thaïlande puisque le premier ministre
est un ancien général putschiste cela
dit je crois que en effet la france
considère qu'elle a un rôle à jouer avec
l'union européenne il ya en peine à un
nouveau concept indo indo pacifique et
la france se considère comme une
puissance de la région puisqu'il y a des
territoires français dans le pacifique
et dans l'océan indien merci beaucoup
claude pour votre éclairage l'édito
diplo de claude blanchemaison c'est tous
les mardis matin dans la matinale à
revoir sur les réseaux sociaux bien
évidemment merci